if you have not heard the news
the supreme court just totally smacked
down the biden osha mandate they upheld
the
the healthcare worker mandate but in
terms of the osha mandate they
effectively struck it down it's slightly
more complicated but effectively they
struck down the vaccine so i wanted to
go on
to you know drink my life to steers
smoke my good cigar and go through
this opinion this is the opinion supreme
court of the united states national
federation of independent businesses
and other applicants
versus the department of labor
specifically osha this is the lawsuit
that the daily wire was involved in
we're helping to lead it which is why
today because we won you can go to
dailywire.com and subscribe to get 44 00
off using code winning
which is just terrific so i've read the
opinion
it's awesome i figured this would be a
good opportunity to just go through
exactly how awesome it is that way you
don't need to read it
the money line
applicants now seek emergency relief
from this court arguing that osha's
mandate exceeds its statutory authority
and is otherwise unlawful agreeing that
applicants are likely to prevail we
grant their applications and stay the
rules so they stay the rules so they say
okay the mandate is on hold for right
now now what's going to happen the
courts are going to let the legal
process play out so that the applicants
can say okay we don't want to have the
ocean mandate in our in our businesses
and what the supreme court is saying is
because we believe that the people who
are applying to the other courts are
likely to succeed content we're telling
you that this thing is illegal and
unconstitutional we're going to stay the
mandate now so the the process is still
going to play out but the court is is
telling you in black and white that the
mandate is unconstitutional okay
so then they go through the history of
osha
they go through
the history of this particular
vaccine issue starting with kovid and
then they point out that the sixth
circuit so the fifth circuit court of
appeals where our lawsuit and others
went to they said okay we're going to
stop the mandate from going into effect
the sixth circuit said no while the
legal process plays out we're going to
force you all to go along with the
mandate
here's the quote the sixth circuit
concluded
that a stay of the rule was not
justified
we disagree boom owned libs take it
applicants are likely to succeed on the
merits of their claim that the secretary
lacked the authority to impose the
mandate
the secretary has ordered 84 million
americans to either obtain a covid
vaccine or undergo weekly medical
testing at their own expense this is no
quote everyday exercise of federal power
so they are again you see the applicants
are likely to succeed why because we're
the supreme court we're saying that
they're likely to shake
skip a little skip a little the question
then
is whether the act the act authorizing
ocean that creates this occupational
safety agency that then presumes to
force 84 million americans to take the
fatchie that the question is whether the
act plainly authorizes the secretary's
mandate
it does not
spoiler alert it does not the act
empowers the secretary to set workplace
safety standards not broad public health
measures so yeah they can they can make
you wear a helmet if you're on a
construction site yeah they can make you
wear a mask actually if you're working
with asbestos but
they can't make you take this permanent
vaccine because of some tangentially
related
pandemic that's going on that obviously
that isn't nearly focused on the
workplace so what this is what they said
they say the solicitor general does not
dispute
this is the government's lawyer does not
dispute that osha is limited to
regulating work-related dangers right
you see a narrow edge she instead argues
that the risk of contracting coven
qualifies as such a danger court says we
cannot agree although it's a risk in
many workplaces it's not an occupational
hazard
covid19 can and does spread at home in
schools during supporting events and
everywhere else people gather that kind
of universal risk is no different from
day-to-day dangers that we all face
air pollution crime any other number of
communicable diseases would be like osha
going in and passing regulations about
violent crime in the streets that's
clearly not what this agency was tasked
with when congress created
osha's indiscriminate approach fails to
account for this crucial distinction
between occupational risk and risk more
generally and accordingly the mandate
takes on the character of a general
public health mission so this is what we
were all afraid of we said
if this rule is allowed to stand
then we don't govern ourselves anymore
and the senate doesn't govern us and the
house doesn't govern us and frankly even
the president doesn't exactly govern us
it's all of these unaccountable headless
probably godless bureaucrats in the
executive agencies think of the fouchies
of the world
six presidents come and go we're now on
the seventh dr fauci remains dr fauci is
just there he has more power than
probably any of them did certainly at
various points in their presidency so
those are going to get to see this is a
this is an important line
the most noteworthy action
concerning the vaccine mandate that was
made by either the house
by either house of congress meaning the
house of reps or the senate
has been a majority vote of the senate
disapproving the regulation on december
8th 2021. so
one of the big issues here is well hold
on
what is the legislature saying this is
something that the legislature should do
not some regular
unaccountable bureaucracy so what has
the legislature given any indication
either that they empower ocean to make
this decision or that they even support
the rule and no they haven't actually
it's the opposite
the houses of congress voted and there
was a resolution asked to disapprove of
the mainland so really
pretty clear and then this is how they
round out the opinion
although congress has indisputably given
osha the power to regulate occupational
dangers it has not given that agency the
power to regulate public health more
broadly right requiring the vaccination
of 84 million americans selected simply
because they work for employers with
more than 100 employees certainly falls
in that category
they stay the mandate it is so ordered
the concurring opinion the conservative
concurring opinion
begins with the whole issue
the central question we face today is
who decides
who decides it's not iskovid really
dangerous the question is not
should people get the vaccines the
question is
who has the right to decide
whether or not
to mandate 84 million americans take
this experimental drug against a cough
the only question rights gorsuch
is whether an administrative agency in
washington one charged with overseeing
workplace safety
may mandate the vaccination or regular
testing of 84 million people and this is
where it gets really based because some
some conservatives have made this
argument that you know we have bodily
autonomy and you can never the
government can never regulate me and
force me to take an inoculation of any
sort that's not true
going back to the earliest days of this
country george washington forced his
troops to take a smallpox inoculation
that killed a ton of them it was much
more dangerous than to have inoculations
than it is today
going back to what was in 1905 the
jacobellis case that was generally this
case
no jacob said i was confused
there was a case over a hundred years
ago that stated that local governments
does have the right to impose vaccine
mandates inoculation mandates and you
could get out of it perhaps if it was
fine or whatever but
still they asserted the authority
of
at least state governments or local
governments to impose these kinds of
mandates and that's what the
conservatives admit they say there's no
question that state and local
authorities possess considerable power
to regulate public health
the federal government's powers however
are not general but limited and divided
big difference what you see here
in in the conservative
concurring opinion is a recognition if
an administrative agency is going to do
something drastic
it needs to be clear that congress gave
them that authority
he said he says that when it comes to
this obligation the court has
established at least one firm
we expect congress to speak clearly if
it wishes to assign to an executive
agency decisions of vast economic and
political significance it's obviously
mandating that 84 million people take a
vaccine that clearly is a broad vast
significant
demand and they say osha's mandate fails
that doctrine's test
they go on they point out that the
senate rejected it they point out that
point out that
the agency only pursued this apparently
as a workaround because the legislature
didn't want to have the vaccine they
point out that far less consequential
agency rules have run afoul of this
major questions doctrine and obviously
this one does too he says in here
this is the the liberty we'll say
this has previously been regu it has
previously regulated infectious disease
including by facilitating infections
talking about ocean
notice that weasel language
osha's already
regulated infectious disease by
facilitating infections or facilitating
vaccinations
well hold on what was that verb you used
facilitating because that's not what's
at issue we're not talking about
facilitating a vaccine we're not saying
that
osha can regulate the ways employers for
instance give employees the opportunity
to get a flu shot we're talking about
mandated vaccination that's a completely
different thing and is unprecedented and
osha has in other contexts required
medical examinations and face coverings
for employees
yeah sure
on construction sites
or in hospitals
you might
require
certain employees to wear certain kinds
of face coverings
osha has never said
that
million tens of millions almost 100
million americans need to wear secular
kefias all the time they need to wear
the the liberal burqa so that they don't
get their filthy peasant germs on
everyone else it's never happened it's
it that
also is really weak i think disingenuous
arguments and then you get here on to
number four even if the merits were a
close question which they are not they
are not the merits are not even close
the conservatives are totally wrong the
court would badly air by issuing this
stay that is because a court may not
issue a stay unless the balance of harms
and the public interest support the
action so they're saying it's so obvious
here that it's the benefits of the of
the vaccine mandate outweigh the costs
and the benefits to the public interest
but as we've stated previously
it's almost all cost there's very little
benefit
taken on the whole in the opinion of
conservatives moderates independence and
the united states senate and majority of
americans there's very little
in the way of benefit versus the cost so
that too is just
it reminds me of the big lebowski
it's a grill actually it's good i'm
smoking it
he was not smoking a cigar
that's just like your opinion ma'am yeah
that's that is just the opinion of the
lib judges without really any serious
argument underlying everything else in
this dispute is a single simple question
it's the same question the conservatives
are asking
or a similar question who decides how
much protection and of what kind
american workers need from covet 19.
an agency with expertise in workplace
health and safety acting as congress and
the president authorized
or a court lacking any knowledge of how
to safeguard workplaces and insulated
from responsibility for any damage it
causes
you know those aren't the only two
options
ladies and
gentlemen
there are some other options who decides
um
the legislature would be a good good
place to decide the people acting
through their elected representatives
might be a good place to start and the
legislature
has voiced its disapproval of this man
employers that might be a good place to
start maybe the employers are permitted
to unless they're hampered from
instituting mandates by local
governments acting as the
representatives of the people that we
see acquired
that would be a good place to start
maybe local communities
why are the only options the supreme
court of the united states and some
bureaucrats
whatever happened to the people's
representatives
they don't want to talk about that
because that undercuts your narrative
cheers wonderful day enjoy the tears and
the smokes and your freedom and
wavelength